das ist ein super dino stärker schneller
beweglicher im süden der usa wurde das
fossil eines echten super dinosaurier
gefunden der seinen verwandten weit
voraus war
das beeindruckende fossil zeigt wie hoch
entwickelt die tiere kurz vor ihrem ende
durch den asteroiden einschlag
tatsächlich waren der dino gehört zur
familie der raptoren und bestätigt dass
diese in einem punkt wurde ganz anders
ausgesehen haben als wir es aus jurassic
park und anderen film kennen klicks
major-sieg die spannende videos aus den
bereichen umwelt und natur abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
sie sind schnelle brutale jäger auf zwei
beinen und wir alle kennen sie aus
filmen wie jurassic park unter dem namen
raptoren dieser begriff wird oft für
alle vertreter der gruppe der drohmails
riten genutzt verglichen mit dem
berühmten tyrannosaurus rex waren sie
zwar eher klein aber mit ihren scharfen
krallen waren sie trotzdem hoch
gefährliche räuber fossilen funde zeigen
dass es vom mittel jura bis zur
oberkreide zahlreiche arten von ihnen
gab die weit verbreitet waren jetzt
wurde in new mexico ein neuer verwandter
des sogenannten hollywood-stars
velociraptor entdeckten diese entdeckung
beleuchtet die entwicklungsgeschichte
man muss sagen die erfolgsgeschichte der
drohmails augen kurz bevor die ära der
dinosaurier durch einen
asteroideneinschlag beendet wurde der
fund war ein echter glücksfall da die
knochenreste durch die verwitterung aus
einem kleinen hügel herausragten das
fossil lag im san juan becken in new
mexico und es besteht aus 20
knochenfragmente die vermutlich aus der
zeit von vor 67 millionen jahren stammt
der gefundenen saurier wurde die neo
bella tor
foto hess perrons getauft was so viel
bedeutet wie navarro krieger aus dem
südwesten und der name krieger trifft
auf diesen saurier absolut zu steven
jasinski von der university of
pennsylvania in philadelphia hat mit
seinem team die überreste wie ein puzzle
zusammengesetzt und konnte so die
gestalt des sauriers und seine merkmale
untersuchen sie stellten fest dass es
sich um einen bisher unbekannten
vertreter geld romeo saurier handelte
das tier war etwa einen meter hoch und 2
meter lang und wog bis zu 22 kilo
es hatte die töpfe schmale schnauze
lange arme mit krallen
und eine sichelförmige kralle am fuß der
möchte ich echt nicht begegnet sein
außerdem hatte der saurier einen langen
beweglichen schwanz der bei
verfolgungsjagten für die balance des
zweibeiner sorgt so weit war ein
typischer dino seiner art aber innerhalb
seiner familie war er ein besonders hoch
entwickeltes tier sozusagen ein super
sommer an den merkmalen seiner mit
krallen besetzten arme sieht man dass er
sie flexibler bewegen konnte als andere
arten damit war er außerordentlich gut
darin seine beute festzuhalten das waren
wahrscheinlich kleinere tiere wie vögel
oder eidechsen mit seinen flexiblen
armen und den krallen bewährten füßen
könnte er aber auch andere dinosaurier
arten gejagt haben schließlich war er
auch ausgesprochen stark denn an seinem
oberarmknochen fand man eine
charakteristische beuge die weist darauf
hin dass die daran befestigten muskeln
effizienter arbeiten konnten als bei
seinen verwandten und auch sein schwanz
war anders denn die meisten raptoren
drucken er gradlinig zum körper und die
steifen schwänzen dienten vor allem als
gegengewicht damit die tiere beim laufen
nicht nach vorne über kippten der die
noble ator konnte seinen fortsatz aber
stark abwinkeln weil die schwanz basis
ungewöhnlich flexibel war
wenn seine beute dann zum beispiel im
zickzack vom flüchtete konnte er mit
seinem flexiblen schwanz schneller die
richtung ändern und das macht ihnen
insbesondere im offenen gelände zu einem
überlegenen jäger so kennt man ihn auch
aus dem film aber in einem punkt
unterscheidet sich der raptor klar von
seiner darstellung auf der leinwand
vermutlich hatten alle raptoren federn
und man geht davon aus dass sie auch mit
dem frühen vögeln verwandt waren das
bestätigt dieser fossile fund denn an
den unterarmknochen des tieres wurden
kleine beulen gefunden in denen die
federn steckten all seine besonderen
merkmale zeigten dass der die noble ator
ein echtes spitzenmodell am ende der
evolutionsgeschichte der trommel sei
rieden war bei seinem ableben konnten
sie ihm trotzdem nicht retten das fossil
wies spuren eines tödlichen kampfes auf
den der raptor wohl verloren hat
trotzdem war er ein bemerkenswerter
vertreter der fleischfressenden
dinosaurier der kurz vor dem grossen
aussterben der saurier lebte
das forschungsteam hofft jetzt auf
weitere spannende funde von dieser oder
anderen arten die mehr einblicke in die
spät kreidezeitlichen tierwelt im süden
der heutigen usa
neben denn während manche die nur
forscher spekulieren dass die
urzeitechsen schon länger zu grunde
gehen bevor der asteroid sie endgültig
ausgelöscht bestätigt der neue fund für
jasinski und sein team dass zumindest
ein teil der dinosaurier sich noch
erfolgreich weiterentwickelt schließlich
scheinen sie sich noch weiter
diversifiziert und neue revolutionäre
wege beschritten zu haben erste dino dna
gefunden wird jurassic park es möglich
hammer video auf einem hammer kanal
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
und zwar die neugier zone meine absolute
empfehlung bis dann bleibt dran